[Musique]
c'est dans la somptueuse galerie des
Affaires étrangère que la ville du Roi
Soleil présente sa nouvelle exposition
les trésors des bibliothèques de
Versailles elle se décline en six étapes
et six thématiques comme la rareté des
œuvres leur esthétique ou encore leur
auteur ça paraît évident de présenter
des trésors dans une bibliothèque
patrimoniale ce qui moins évident c'est
de les choisir parce qu'en fait ici nous
avons une histoire qui est extrêmement
riche faite de
décennies de travail sur des collections
qui sont souvent de très riche
provenance au total la bibliothèque de
versaill dispose de 500000 ouvrages dans
cette exposition ce sont 160 œuvres qui
ont été sélectionnées si vous devez
venir voir quelque chose dans cette
exposition je ne peux que vous
conseiller d'aller voir le sybalom Mundi
un livre extraordinairement rare le seul
exemplaire que nous conservons l'édition
originale Donkey shot de migel servantes
trésor de la littérature mondiale et
peut-être attardez-vous dans la dernière
salle pour voir des faux trésors mais
qui peuvent se révéler de vrais trésors
autre manuscrit inédit exposer les
petits livres secrets rédigés par Madame
de maintenant la maîtresse de Louis XIV
l'exposition les trésors des
bibliothèques de Versailles est gratuite
et en accès libre vous pouvez venir la
visiter du mercredi au samedi après-midi
jusqu'au 16 décembre